[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous êtes en train de
faire un
parfum j'accueille mais pour un mort
weborama parce que vous en effet pour
des vivants aussi en europe oui j'ai
déjà arrivé plusieurs fois comment
s'est-elle comment ça va se passer comme
ça
c'est un jour ça s'est passé le 22
janvier le l'an dernier
en revenant nous fait un mise en bière
comme ça je reçois les rentrées barras
verre dans un café ou café lirian quand
on l'a vu tout à l'heure et puis tombe
sur un copain brun vert et puis les
rogues d'iwaki dit j'aurai mon cercueil
de mon vivant en guinée que celui qui
l'habitait évidemment des enfants il
avait fait 105 adhérents et il a vécu
trés mieux dans leurs rangs ont bravé au
bout d'un moment du temple hill on
décide chaque été dans le six mois
qu'ils réfléchissent parler des
bouteilles de champagne vous dit que
quand je vais me dégonfle beauté trouve
pas du tout cas bon dieu l'appellera le
veut dire un petit peu c'est ce qui est
arrivé à des gains alors je fais
présenté les six rapports je prends un
crayon feutre et chaque hôtel sur
l'épaule qui soit certaine angoisse qui
avait hésité toujours la capote et des
bouteilles de champagne relevé le modem
europe
récemment entre le lien social mort des
personnes et pourquoi tu fais ça parce
que c'est pour un vivant mais il vous
qui sais pas je dis c'est pas un tel pas
m'étendre pape lui
c'est pas mal
et sa femme que ce qu'elle a dit bon
sang froid moore ben c'est à dire en
aller après des questions un peu froide
parce que
alors que mona et perrier-jouët de s'y
recueillir 1 2 juillet sur yon pas
d'autres c'est de pas mal de juillet
alors avant que je dirais gars allez on
y va alors être à 5,6 à des allemands où
je dois pas
bomber j attendais on va passer par la
porte je m'emmêle une femme a eu droit
aux affaires et ce couloir alors bon je
dis les gars tu allais mais j'en arrive
en coin de tourner on va passer par ce
n'est
pas nouveau et ça alors je vais le
fenêtre à san luis bedoya haderer alors
se met en route je suis allé lô a
réparti de ne pas redémarrer ailleurs
les gars je dirais surtout pas du flan
les batteries il faut le placer alors
je plonge approché d'un fenêtre juste à
face des jolies mais j'ai pas toujours
s'il n'y en a pas pas la chance du grand
crohot terre ennemie loger dans be tous
à la culture réveille la nuit je
t'attends cortège d'une mère dire
personne alors je passerai devant les
gendarmes et du maire de
sinfra street le groupe va être obligé
de l'arrivée de la maison qui était
votre vie pendant une semaine binger
pendant une semaine le portement de
fredo pas des gens comme une femme on y
présente pas de déchets dans la maison
figurez-vous j'ai mangé des subaru
cependant ue l'ajout matin jean minjoz
en rédigeant linge ou un soir alors
étrangers ces reports mais dans le
journée aussi une femme et une belle
mère il avait changé de place au lieu
des déchets surface des chenils l'on me
lâche loire accès de la ville et à
rester l'autre alors après son contrat
tout
[Musique]
ça va au critique dans la guide il bradé
celui qui les fait le premier l'alba
avec celui qui l'a fait la veille à 2003
des terres croyez vous sépare placement
d'argent un des héritiers qu'est ce qui
aurait mené et comme ils sont pas encore
bien vieux sais-je encore 20 ans arrive
ou bien la portée de la quête et eric
iorio six mois après jour pour jour j'ai
déjà mais lui c'était pas pour faire
l'inversé il est gardien à la zambie la
déshabille ya pas il n'y a pas un petit
thé pourcentage qui va alain auffray
erreur ce qu'il a dit comme ça
andré
mathieu ça fait longtemps que vous êtes
là bas non programmeurs et vous venez
souvent de votre cercueil bas tous les
semaines je l'essaie
pourquoi vous êtes se faire incertaine
et bages et une déclaration mettant le
prix j'ai fabriqué ce copain
retrouver six mois il ya christian et
promis mais au bout de six mois et demi
à la dre et après le petit suisse
qu'est-ce qu'on fait demain je l'essaie
vous avez des poignets à votre porte de
cercueils et vous comptez l'utiliser
[ __ ] à réceptionner et je connais ta
télé avec nous je crois que ça peut
servir à bien sûr la cgpme gawlik et
celle au gym suite
oui mais pas que vous ayez tout au moins
quand vous n'êtes pas dans votre cercle
et vous il vous sert à quoi nash pour
une pandémie mais abidal
[Musique]
et vous passez vos goûts tant par
semaine d'un os demi heure les seuils ça
vous pensez à quoi quand vous êtes dans
charmed et là à ben je crois qu'on va
vous laisser vous délasser merci aux
fleurs du bien
[Musique]